uh jen saki uh was just asked a very
difficult question and she didn't have a
very good answer what's going on at the
southern border right now
is that coyotes are hurling hispanic
children
over the border peter ducey
brings this question up to jen saki he
says hey you know your border policies
don't seem to be working that well
if it's if it's incentivizing criminal
cartels
to just hurl children across the border
what are you guys doing about that
on immigration has the white house
considered beefing up border security
now that there is video of a
three-year-old
and a five-year-old being thrown over
the
wall in new mexico beefing up border
security
well there are there's video now of a
three-year-old
i've seen the video and i think any of
us who saw the video um
were incredibly alarmed by uh the steps
of smugglers
ones that we have been quite familiar
with that we've spoken out about our
concerns
about as secretary mayor said the
inhumane way smugglers abuse children
while profiting off parents desperation
is criminal
and morally reprehensible president
certainly agrees with that
oh good i'm glad to hear that the
president agrees with that
but why is he still pursuing policies
that encourage the behavior
if you've got effectively an open border
if you're
pursuing catch and release if you're
saying the kids get to stay
then what do you think is going to
happen the coyotes are going to start
throwing the kids over the border
they're making a lot of money doing this
there was a coyote just the other day
told univision business is booming
the president of mexico blamed joe biden
for what's going on
everyone in the country is blaming joe
biden for this but biden doesn't want to
take responsibility
it's quite clear while the border has
always been an issue things have gotten
much much worse under biden because
biden said come here
come surge get over here so
jen you know he might have the best of
intentions
but look at what's going on look at what
his policies are actually resulting in
what's your answer to it jen these kids
i believe were
rescued from by uh by um individuals who
are working at the border
yes but they still got close enough
as you guys are talking about addressing
root causes in the region for a smuggler
to throw them
over a wall into the desert and i'm just
curious what
the white house is doing to stop that
from happening
and are you concerned more about the
kids safety or are you concerned about
kids getting in or tell me more about
your concern here kid safety
is as you just mentioned the main
concern well
of course it is which is why i'm often
surprised by some of the line of
questioning here but
i will say that um our concern and our
focus
is on sending a clear message to
smuggler to
the region that uh this is not the time
to come
not the time to come not the time to
come
we want to send a very clear message
about this issue of violating our laws
and
we want to send a very clear message
wait until next week
come on come on man a ver this is a very
clear message we are not going to
tolerate
this sort of thing until at least
2 p.m today so just don't you know hey
come on we're being serious come on man
the that's not even the most egregious
part of that exchange
peter ducey asked the very serious
question why are we allowing these
criminals to get close enough to hurl
three-year-olds over the wall
in gensake she says well hold on peter
is your concern
the law or is your concern the safety of
the children i want to know about your
concern
i don't care about peter ducey's concern
why
why should anybody care about peter
ducey's
inner most concerns and motivations i
care about the question he's asking
which is the
actual policy well yeah but what are you
what are your intentions what are your
feelings
peter all right first of all by the way
you can both be concerned about the
safety of the children and the safety
of the american people and the
enforcement of our laws that were passed
through
the democratic process here in the
country that at one time was governed
underneath under a constitution you can
be concerned about all i'm concerned
about the whole thing
jen why is it that it's only permissible
to be concerned about the little
children
but it's not permissible to be concerned
about the enforcement of the law
conservatives sometimes fall into making
these arguments too
which is if you're talking about say the
injustice of affirmative action policies
that you know disadvantage white and
asian students in college and job
applications
and give an unfair advantage to black
and hispanic students
sometimes you will hear people say look
it's actually it's really it's unfair
to the the students who get the
advantage because then they'll be it'll
be look they'll be looked at as though
they didn't
deserve to get in that will follow them
their career it's
it's the soft bigotry of low
expectations it's really unfair to them
sure okay it is also unfair to the
people it's
disadvantaging yes it's true that what's
going on at the border
is unfair to these children it's
creating awful incentives and it's bad
to put kids in cages yeah that's true
that is bad
it's also unfair to the american people
and it's not it's not illegitimate
to mention the concerns of the american
people and the enforcement of our laws
the only interest jen saki has the only
pseudo argument she can make
is about motivations and intentions
and psychobabble if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you